you know I'm very pleased today because
we have a visitor Connor from languages
are everybody and we have so many things
in common it's really quite exciting to
have someone like you visit interested
in languages interested in Ukraine which
I've been following for better for worse
over the last two years and Connor's
actually been living in Ukraine so
before getting into all of it you tell
people cuz it was quite exciting to hear
how you move around you're a digital
nomad exactly so didja know if people
who don't know are people who work
online and they can live basically
anywhere because the most important
thing they need in terms of work is the
internet right so you can do this with
so many different businesses you can be
an independent contractor for example
you could be an accountant you could be
a translator and you can do your
business online and you can find your
clients that way or you can do the work
and that then allows you to live
basically whenever you want wherever you
want we're in a few restrictions like
for example time zones are always a bit
of a killer right so if you happen to
work with New York and anyone live in
Australia can be a little bit can be a
little bit complicated but in theory
it's technology in the last ten years
has developed to allow us to do most of
the work remotely if we want to in a lot
of areas that's where this wasn't
possible before so that's basically
what's become the digital nomads and
they could be it can be things that you
don't necessarily have to have a
profession for because I know that Steve
was a diplomat for a long time that's a
tricky one such a long time right but no
I was a diplomat for seven years I was
most of them as in the wood it would be
Oh within some but for those who can't
place Connors accent Connor is
originally from ireland zaki i did a
video about this recently yeah and how
much I'm kind of mocked even when i get
back to ireland by the taxi drivers
because the first question they ask is
where you from sir cry and when i say my
hometown i was born in Galway in the
West of Ireland they reply oh that's
very nice so how long have you been
living in our country right assuming
that I'm a recent immigrant me on the
the channel is not a great of the big
fan and you've always been a great
inspiration so it will be lowering
language sorry okay hey bye bye bye